eleven years ago was my first trip to
Antarctica
I came down here to do a story about the
behavior of the leopard seal
my name is Paul Nicklin it's my job as a
photojournalist to capture the
importance and the fragility of this
place and bring this back to the world
Antarctica is a beautiful place
but it comes at a price it's the getting
there that's the hard part
we have to cross 550 miles of the
roughest seas in the world
that's a 90 degree shift constantly 24
hours a day
but after four days of being confined to
your bunk it's like you're entering this
dream line and the dream is real
[Music]
[Music]
what I love the most about Antarctica is
that nothing is afraid of me
[Music]
it is not a place where I feel lonely to
be floating there in the water and then
like a ghost a humpback whale comes
cruising by
reaches out with a pectoral fin to see
what I made of or what I'm doing in
their waters
[Music]
it's like coming back to see my old
friend
[Music]
and then to launch the zodiac and then
to cruise alone amongst the icebergs
it's my homecoming in a land that you
dream of when you're not there
[Music]
you're just a speck in this landscape of
beauty my only job at that point is
creating these visuals that I can bring
back to the world
I know there are leopard seals in the
area
and the water in a rare moment is clear
and I'm excited if there's a chance to
meet a leopard seal in these conditions
but I'm also apprehensive by slipping
below that that curtain of the surface
and looking underwater I don't know
what's gonna come and approach me every
leopard seal is an individual
[Music]
they are a thousand pounds they are
twelve feet long they are bigger than a
grizzly bear
[Music]
these leopard seals have never seen a
human being in their hunting grounds
before
the secret to any big wildlife predator
is to let it dictate the encounter they
do these big dramatic threat displays
and
[Music]
I love it because you know that there
they're putting on a big show
[Music]
when curiosity overrides fear at that
point you've got the seal and the seal
has you and in this case I think the
leopard seal became incredibly proud to
show me how to catch a penguin how to
hold the penguin and how to survive in
this icy world
[Music]
they are so smart they want to
communicate with you and that's the
beauty of these interactions is that
these animals are trying to solve you
[Music]
you can watch in their eyes looks like
they're smiling they just love to have
fun
[Music]
I need to transport people into this
world with the seal and to realize how
beautiful it is and yet how fragile its
ecosystem where it lives is
[Music]
their ecosystem is crumbling around them
because of the lives that were leading
the only chance it has for survival is
us as humans changing our behaviors
[Music]